[Music]
hi I'm Mike at röszke we're here at cute
con EU in Copenhagen and I'm here with
Jason E from data doc how are you hey
I'm doing all right so tell me what data
dog does yeah we're a SAS based
monitoring platform so we help customers
collect their metrics infrastructure
metrics application metrics traces so
thinking of APM and their logs all in
one place and so how do I use that to
look at my kubernetes metrics yeah so we
have kubernetes integrations already
built in so whether you're running your
kubernetes and gke or if you're running
it just on your own standalone on-prem
stuff all of that all of that metrics
can be gathered up and sent to us so you
can see it all in one place that's super
cool yeah makes it really handy for
people that are in in that hybrid cloud
situation where they're just playing
around with maybe they need some stuff
on Prem maybe they're migrating to the
cloud it's really helpful to have
everything in one place as you're doing
that I think pane of glass we totally
get that
yeah anything else you want to talk
about about data dog and Google we love
Google yeah yeah it's been here it's
been really great to to partner with
Google on not only integrations on
technical things but also with events
because Google has a bunch of great
events like Google cloud next in Google
a
so it's always nice to be a part of
those and see the Google ecosystem
growing and having more people there who
are obviously adopting can you know
container technology kubernetes things
like that and so where do I go to find
out more about running data dog on gke
yeah you can find out more at data dog
HQ com are you using committees and
monitor criminales we are so a big big
project for us in this year is trying to
shift all of our applications to be
containerized it helps us be a little
bit more standardized that help us to
roll out wherever we need to without you
know the the fear of things being
fragile right when they're in virtual
machines or they're just actually on
servers so as we're we're rolling out
kubernetes is a big plan or a big part
of that because just makes managing
containers so much easier so yeah we
help our customers who are running
kubernetes monitor their communities but
it's also all running on our kubernetes
Turtles all the way down it is thank you
so much thanks
and thank you to all of those at home
watching and have fun
you